Nicaragua no negocia su soberanía con
estas palabras Daniel Ortega negó que la
decisión de enviar hacia Estados Unidos
a 222 presos políticos fuera parte de un
acuerdo no estamos pidiendo que nos
levante una sanción no estamos pidiendo
nada a cambio en un asunto de honor de
dignidad de Patriotismo que se llevan a
sus mercenarios los excarcelados fueron
recibidos en Washington por amigos y
familiares entre ellos los precandidatos
presidenciales Juan Sebastián Chamorro y
Félix maradiaga no fuimos avisados
obviamente de que habíamos salido libre
sino que nos dimos cuenta al momento de
que nos dieron nuestra ropa en la noche
Nos llevaron a otra celda sí se nos hizo
firmar una nota donde dice que estamos
simple muy escueta una línea simplemente
que voluntariamente salimos del país sin
ninguna otra explicación del proyecto de
la mayoría oficialista en el parlamento
de revocarles la ciudadanía nicaragüense
se enteraron durante en ningún momento
se decía que renunciaba simplemente que
estábamos saliendo voluntariamente del
país una sola línea Obviamente que un
trámite de esa naturaleza no nos quita
la nicaraguanidad que tenemos sino que
nos sentimos mucho más orgullosos y más
comprometidos con Nicaragua sin embargo
no todos los precios políticos fueron
desterrados según Ortega el obispo
Rolando Álvarez detenido desde agosto
acusado de Conspiración se negó a
recibir el beneficio cuando él etapa
haciendo la fila ya llega Pues a la
grada del avión entonces
empieza a decir que
el que él no se va que primero tendría
que hablar con los obispos tras su
negativa marcharse el obispo de
matagalpa pasó de prisión domiciliaria a
la cárcel modelo de Nicaragua